the homecoming is tonight san
francisco's oracle park home to madison
baumgarner for more than a decade
tonight he returns as a member of the
arizona diamondbacks some unbelievable
moments in that ballpark and mad bum
right at the heart of it all
and this time he'll face his former
teammates in a regular season game for
the first time on the hill tonight for
the giants will be the right-hander
trevor cahill
cahill is 32 years of age he's in his
11th year at the big league level big
guys he's been very good 18 strikeouts
in 14 and a third nine walks a bit high
still a two to one strikeout walk ratio
and now a chance for christian walker
christian drives that deep to right
field the ostrenski is there here comes
calhoun
rbi for christian walker diamondback
strike first in san francisco should
have lefty madison bumgarner
after a month on the injured list with a
back problem he returns tonight against
his old club where he was part of this
franchise's dna for 11 seasons wilmer
flores the second baseman making his way
to the plate
[Applause]
long throw for eduardo escobar juarez
does not run all that well
two ounce from madison bumgarner mike
kestremski the right fielder
and his dremski lifts it out to center
field dalton varshall makes a running
grab
three outs on seven pitches a terrific
start for mad bum who leads it one
nothing ahmed had three hits last night
got him
rob drake made the call
this is over and up part can't be wrong
longoria is all for for a long lifetime
against bumgarner and the count is one
ball and one strike
bringing a high fly ball to the left
peralta back looking up
out of here
and this game is tied
and here he tries to throw it in there
right at the belt and that wasn't far
off from the mark
and here's ruff
ruff drives one to center field
varshall back looking up
out of here
and the giants take the lead bumgarner
knew right away that's just power right
there
rookie catcher 250. carson kelly back
there for him
our chases a high pitch there and
strikes out but longoria and ruff go
back to back it's 2-1 san francisco 2-2
to calhoun and the 2-2 pitch
is a sweat you're going to miss good
pitch from cahill that's his second
strikeout center fielder mauricio dubois
2-2 on dubon
called strike three second strikeout for
madboon wilmer flores bounced out to
third and his only other at-bat
lined on the left-field line into the
corner and this is a fair ball and it'll
bounce over the wall so doubles for
flores marshall bounced out to
wilmer flores
in the second inning and the one two
he got him swinging to end the inning
so berger pitches through the lead off
single it's longoria to lead it off
here's the shortstop robertson who's
over one
and is ripped to left field and david
peralta reaches up and snags it
everybody has to scamper back to the
bags
boy robertson barreled that up a line
drive right at david in left field nice
play david at the last instant throwing
that glove up in the air it's a full
count
got him
here comes katel martin
got him you got a piece of it
strikes out two giants are coming up
austin slater the dh leads it off
martay spins and smothers that one and
ahmed
can't quite turn two
and slater runs very well any play there
by katel martin nick christian walker
facing
the giants lefty
[Applause]
got him back door breaking ball right
there at the knees outside corner kind
of wrapped around the outside part of
the plate
escobar one for two
like this like that four
six three and that'll end the inning
good call brother he's struck out and
he's bounced out to second
hit into left center field and hit well
peralta on the move and it's off the
bottom of the wall
bell will score bart is going to try for
three is he going to make it he made it
with a triple
just over
the outstretched arm
here's deubon
and he hits a high drive to right
calhoun's looking up and it's off of
archway number five
dubon is digging for three
here's the throw to third who's got a
triple
back-to-back triples and the giants lead
four to one dalton barshow the center
fielder tonight 0 for two
[Applause]
varsity down the line dalton varshall
his first major league home run is in
mccovey cove
two on and two out for escobar
that one is throw into left field there
comes cattell martay le castro will stop
at second
rbi for escobar and it's a one-run ball
game
hit to left hit well dickerson back at
the wall and that's the ball game
a sire lead from tony watson
and the giants end up winning this one
by one run
4-3 they'll take it